now at the same time as the the mayors
and the governor's and and the kind of
liberal elite are doubling down on
everything the new york times is
admitting that actually maybe the
lockdowns aren't having that big of a
health effect at all there's this
article that comes out from of all
places the New York Times New York Times
says life has to go on house Sweden has
faced the virus without a lockdown
you remember basically every country in
the world shut down total lockdown crash
the global economy except for Sweden
those Swedes weren't going to hear it
they basically stayed open so the New
York Times has to admit now the country
was an outlier in Europe trusting its
people to voluntarily follow its
protocols many heaven but it does not
seem to have hurt them Swedes they said
could be trusted to stay home follow
social distancing protocols and wash
their hands to slow the spread of the
virus without any mandatory orders and
to a large extent Sweden does seem to
have been as successful in controlling
the virus as most other nations so then
what have we been doing for the past
five weeks if the lockdowns have not put
us in a much much better position than
no lockdowns at all that we see in
Sweden what's the point of the lockdowns
because by the way when the virus comes
back again which it will especially
since we don't have a vaccine in sight
Sweden is going to be in a much better
position because they're going to have
what is called herd immunity or
something close to it by the time it
comes back again that's the whole point
of not locking down times goes on to
admit while other countries were
slamming on the brakes Sweden kept its
borders open gatherings of more than 50
people are banned but that's about it
there are almost no fines and police
officers can only ask people to oblige
that's it and yet Sweden is doing just
fine
so while not just the many studies that
we've talked about on this show over the
past few days and weeks not just the
many models that we've looked at that
haven't come true the doomsday models 2
million Americans dead 4 million
Americans did doesn't look anything like
that as all of the scientific evidence
falls apart for the lockdowns the
liberal elites the mayors and the
governor's and the journalists double
down actually even at the new york times
the putative lee conservative columnist
there Ross Douthat
tweeted out this hot take on the
lockdowns quote the fact that Sweden and
parts of the US right have converged on
the same let the old die for herd
immunity approach to the coronavirus
demonstrates that Nordic socialism and
American libertarianism are the twin
faces of late liberalism siblings not
enemies
send tweet who's got this little kind of
joke at the end sent wheat here's the
first thought that pops into my mind
now the point that Ross Douthat made is
almost a good point it's kind of the
point we made yesterday that there's
this similarity between hyper
individualistic libertarianism and
statist liberalism that actually they're
kind of two sides of the same coin sure
I guess that points right the trouble is
what he's observing about what's
happening is wrong he's saying that
Sweden and parts of the US have
converged on a let the old die for herd
immunity approach well that's not what
his own newspaper is saying about what's
actually happening nobody is suggesting
let the old die for herd immunity what
we're suggesting is there's there's no
alternative to the virus working its way
through the society and there's no
advantage to the lockdown because we
were told to it there are two points of
a lockdown don't overwhelm the health
care system by enough time to get a
vaccine we now know we're not going to
get a vaccine any time soon we know that
the virus is spreading very very quickly
much faster than people predicted it
would and we know that we're not
overwhelming the hospital system saw it
even in New York which was the epicenter
in the United States so the lockdowns
aren't accomplishing anything we know
people are dying from the lockdowns
people always die when you crash the
economy so we're just saying a lot
there's no point to the lock downs the
lock downs are causing more harm than
good that's not this difficult you know
let the old die so that young people can
make more money that's just a fiction
that's a fiction now being promulgated
by people who got it wrong in the first
place they got the lockdowns wrong even
when many of us were saying hey maybe we
should slow down maybe we shouldn't pump
the globe pump the or drive rather the
global economy to a crash okay I get it
people don't like to be wrong
they hate it when the evidence disproves
what they were saying people have got to
move on though okay you've got to react
to the evidence in front of you you
can't become so wrapped up in your own
ideology that you're ignoring the
evidence all around you